si daniel ortega era adolescente cuando
tomo las armas por primera vez fue en
los años 70 cuando se unió a las filas
del frente sandinista de liberación
nacional un movimiento de izquierda que
luchaba contra el dictador gobernante
anastasio somoza tras años de lucha en
1979 los revolucionarios derribaron la
dictadura ortega participó en el
gobierno de transición y cinco años
después fue elegido presidente a pesar
de la promoción de muchas políticas
sociales como la ampliación de la
libertad de prensa y la abolición de la
pena de muerte arrancó una
contrarrevolución en el país apoyada por
eeuu
nicaragua se hundió en una guerra civil
en donde la escasez se multiplicó y la
inflación estalló en 1990 ortega fue
finalmente derrotado en las urnas
enfrentando a violeta chamorro diez años
después cambió su ropa militar por
camisas blancas y sus consignas
marxistas se transformaron en un
programa económico liberal ganó un
segundo mandato en 2007 enmarcado por un
fuerte crecimiento económico y la
inversión extranjera
haciendo de nicaragua
un pueblo
el sólido biberón
ortega se aferró al poder sin descanso y
sobreescribir la constitución incluyendo
la eliminación de los límites de los
mandatos esto le llevó a una cuarta
victoria presidencial por capa hay que
defenderla continuamente hay que
renovarla continuamente ya que tenemos
un ejército para la paz una paz que no
duró mucho en 2018 se presentaron
protestas multitudinarias en managua en
contra de una reforma de la seguridad
social la represión fue sangrienta más
de 300 personas fueron asesinadas y
miles resultaron heridas al menos
100.000 personas huyeron del país desde
entonces más que nunca a ortega y sus
allegados han hecho todo lo posible para
mantenerse en el poder incluso si eso
significa arrestar y encarcelar a todos
sus potenciales oponentes en las
elecciones presidenciales un poco más de
50 años después de que ortega se
levantará en armas contra un dictador
ahora se le acusa de haberse convertido
en uno